how do seasons Diablo for
pork Adam Fletcher thank you so much for
asking me I love to talk about this for
a bit so what's yeah let's talk about
Seasons um all right so we're gonna have
a helpful infographic to show you in
just a second but let me talk to you
about seems as a general rule you know
as we're thinking about Diablo 4 and the
launch product of the game uh we are
trying to make sure that we've got a
really great experience that players are
going to be able to enjoy for their
first you know character playthrough of
the campaign and have an excellent
excellent experience uh seasonal content
are post-launch contents can be arriving
shortly after the launch of the base
game mid to late July mid to late July
actually it's good yeah yeah we haven't
asked we haven't talked about that yet
but absolutely it is mid to late July
you've heard it from reference uh so but
so that's the goal we want to make sure
that you've got enough time to play
through your first character and really
enjoy the campaign at your own pace and
kind of explore potentially different
classes as you go uh so when we're
thinking about seasons and Diablo 4 we
start off with thinking about uh a theme
the seasonal content of that season so
we're gonna have four seasons a year uh
one per quarter and each of these are
going to have a really strong theme
associated with them and this theme is
going to like basically inform the
things we want to do with the with all
the content within the season with
things about appearing in the battle
pass uh things in the seasonal quest
line uh things associated with like the
new gameplay can't actually be adding
this part of that season you really want
to make sure these things feel like
they're connected in one coherent
experience for players when they log in
and they play during the season right
yeah and so then so as part of that
season then to carry that theme forward
and you're going to want to obviously
have some sort of context or narrative
around this season yes yes that's
absolutely right so that leads us to the
seasonal quest line so one of the
questions I see get asked either like
online or occasionally we'll see in like
you know like various chat channels uh
it's just that like how how are we
thinking about story as a as a with
regards like the live service how are we
extending the story of Diablo for and
there's kind of like two approaches the
way that we're looking at things uh with
regards to seasons we're not going to be
using this as an opportunity to expand
upon the campaign story of Diablo 4
right you know the the campaign story of
Diablo 4 featuring like an RS and little
of the events of the of The Wanderer
those events are really going to be told
over the course of our expansions our
post-launch expansions we're not talking
specifically about today you know but
that's really where the the high level
narrative Diablo 4 will continue to
unfold but that leaves our hand open to
do really interesting things in Seasons
so if a season is supposed to have like
a theme with a gameplay mechanic and
things associated with it it allows it
to have like one really engaging
seasonal quest line that manages to
deliver on like a self-contained story
that's going to guide the player through
like again the mechanics and the themes
of that season so like these are still
like really big events that are
happening in the world of sanctuary
where the players gonna be able to like
step in the role of the wander and like
kind of go and help people and like and
explore interesting mechanics right so
you're not bound you're the ideas around
the season are not bound by the campaign
you're you you're basically creating
quest lines in the open world that can
be completely different and completely
uh you know is not it's not constrained
to it has to be about the initiation of
the story it can be about anything
that's sort of interesting you want to
play into in the open world right
absolutely so if for example uh we had a
season theme for the first season which
again we will not be discussing today
folks we're gonna save season one to
talk about a little bit later on yeah we
plan on talking about season one after
launch that's right but let's say for
for sake of argument that the first
season was uh the theme was about
zombies which it is not no this is a
false premise okay let's just say for a
sake of argument that it was about
zombies is the theme that means that
like things would be showing up in the
battle pass might be related to some
like zombie stuff the season quest line
might be about like rising of zombies
throughout Sanctuary like that we try to
make sure these things all feel
connected so let's use a quest line it's
going to introduce new characters uh
like great voice acting uh memorable
quests and experiences will guide the
player through the season and that's the
way they're looking at things and so
then that also then
I feel like I'm doing your job actually
am I doing your job I apologize I'm no
you're you're doing great oh thanks
you're doing amazing um
thank you for the daily affirmation
sorry I I'm just curious like when you
think about the theme you know um that
obviously goes beyond story construct
but also goes into the mechanics like
how you think about gameplay yes
absolutely and that brings us to the
next major thing I want to discuss which
is fresh gameplay this is what I would
this is the greatest
yes so fresh gameplay so with every new
season obviously we'll be introducing
new story content Jerry described uh and
then we want to introduce new mechanics
and gameplay for players to engage with
over the course of that season so this
comes down to things like uh just new
power for players to earn or ways to
experience the growth of their character
these are the modify and change the way
they're going to want to approach
building their character every season
this goes beyond meta changes or like
balance and tuning and things like that
it really come down to like just at like
wholesale like new features and things
that are going to be available for the
duration of that season for players to
experience and then at the the
termination of the season when the
season is over these sorts of features
are going to be retired to be considered
for again in the future if we like them
or not but for now we want to make sure
that we're kind of maintaining a certain
level of parity across the game we're
not kind of creating layers of like
cruft and distraction from the core
Diablo experience which we already feel
is doing very well so yeah we're really
excited to talk about those a little bit
more in the future but you can expect
like exciting new features and gameplay
to engage with between new monsters and
mechanics uh things for players to craft
or do change their gear or just change
their skills so we're really excited
about that stuff in the future
and then when you think about seasonal
stuff we talked about you know the when
you look at say Diablo 3 has the
chapters that you go through to get
Hector's gift and those sorts of things
so that there's a sense of progression
through a season and we we've obviously
talked about the Battle pass and and how
that battle pass will be in our previous
blog around this stuff as well but it's
good to clarify again so when you think
about not just like okay I have a
seasonal narrative I have a seasonal
mechanic or gameplay hook now but how do
I think about progression within a
season sure so great question uh so when
we're thinking about Seasons we want to
make sure we are creating new
opportunities for long-term progression
uh the first version of that we want to
talk about really is the season Journey
which does make a return from Diablo 3.
so inside the season Journey uh the
player is going to have an opportunity
to complete a number of different
objectives that are tied to mechanics uh
story goals or other things are
happening during the course of the
season I think we might actually have an
image for the uh for the season Journey
we can maybe pull up as well that might
help me explain some parts of this I
think we hid the zombie stuff though so
there's no zombies There's no zombie
stuff on this stuff yeah
yes please note the top secret labels
for this because I realize there's no
image we could show that doesn't start
to give away some of the things we're
doing season one too bad you're gonna be
able to talk more we'll talk more about
that a little bit later on but here in
the season Journey players are able to
complete a number of these objectives
since I already called out objectives
are separated into chapters uh one of
the big changes that we made as part of
the Season journey is we've ensured that
now players don't need to actually
complete every one of the objectives
within the chapter in order to advance
they could choose to go back and they're
still confused so if I don't go ahead
yeah it's it's so it's it's pretty
different than if you're a player of
Diablo 3 and you're going through season
Journey if if you remember like going
you going through each chapter required
you to finish every single little bit of
it before you could progress to another
chapter so this one obviously a little
different in how you kind of approach it
because you don't have to do every
single thing you can actually complete
it beforehand by doing most of the
objectives and kind of choosing
specifically yeah like if I'm not a PVP
player I don't have to do the PVP
objective to progress through the
Journey right that's correct if we have
an objective would send you like the
fields of hatred you wouldn't have to go
there with that one you could do the
other objectives associated with the
season instead got it so when you're
going through in your plot you're kind
of completing the season Journey you're
going to earn rewards for completing the
objectives and you'll also earn some big
rewards at the end of each chapter where
you're going to get uh like packs of uh
of like crafting materials and items and
you can also unlock actual uh legendary
aspects will go in your codex of power
so not just earns through dungeons you
can earn through the Yeah a different
set of aspects and faculty available
through the code of power in this way
it's not the new and some of the new
legendary Powers we add in every season
will also be made available through this
method so you'll still be able to find
them as item drops of course but you can
start you can be able to experiment and
play with them pretty early on do these
drops and then the last thing I think is
worth talking about here is every time
you complete one of these objectives
you're going to also be earning favor uh
which is a kind of an experience system
is used by the battle pass but uh
without a ways to get like little drops
from completing the objectives and big
drops of that also from cleaning the
chapters uh but you know when it comes
to launcher progression the battle pass
like would you mind me be walking us
through some of how the battle pass
works yeah absolutely so I know there's
been a lot of questions about battle
pass so let's talk through it today
um so this is the seasons Tab and this
is going to be you know the hub for all
things Seasons under that top secret
label
um you can see the the uh season Journey
um and then at the bottom here you can
see the actual battle pass and what
you're seeing is a mix of the free tiers
and the premium tiers of the battle pass
the way that you progress the battle
pass is like Joe mentioned
um with uh by earning favor and there's
two sources of it uh you get it from the
season Journey like Joe Manson mentioned
but you also get it from leveling up and
playing any seasonal character
um so there's three levels of the battle
pass there's the free track which like
the name implies uh you don't have to
pay for everybody has access to that the
premium track which is roughly 10 US
dollars depending on you know where you
are in the world and then there's the
accelerated track which is just like the
premium track but it has includes 20
tier skips it's you know folks who might
have gotten a late start and a special
cosmetic and that one is roughly 25 USD
depending on where you are in the world
um but let's talk a little bit more
about the free and premium tracks
um
so the free track has 27 total tiers and
what you're primarily getting from the
free track are are what's called
smoldering ashes and the smoldering
ashes are going to be like the currency
that you use to unlock seasonal
blessings
um
so the seasonal blessings are different
Buffs you can get that will help
accelerate your progress through the
season so you can see for example here
um you know plus uh three percent to XP
earned that's going to help players you
know level up again level up multiple
characters
um and all of these are really just
meant to help players through that
seasonal progression through that
seasonal Journey it's important to note
though that you you know there is a
secondary level requirement on every
free tier of the battle pass that
contains uh smoldering ashes so for
example if you were level one and you
bought you know a bunch of tear skips
and hadn't played yet you wouldn't be
able to access the smoldering ashes and
spend them until you had actually like
leveled up a character and met those
level requirements and this is to you
know prevent folks from buying a ton of
tear skips and keep everybody on a level
uh playing Ground so that is I had a
question about that actually so there's
there are no smoldering ashes available
in the premium track of the battle pass
right that is absolutely correct it is
um that all the things that affect
gameplay are only in the free track okay
and so that basically that's we've said
like our it's always cosmetic based so
there's no you don't you can't pay for
power in Diablo 4 because as you saw the
the stuff the season blessings are on
the free track and they have a level
requirement so you actually have to play
to get to a certain point so right it
keeps everybody on a Level Playing Field
right right you may not uh pay for power
in uh Diablo for
um so yeah let's talk about next the the
premium track so like I mentioned ten
dollars USD depending on where you are
in the world and this contains 63 total
reward tiers so you add that to the 27
from the free track you get the 90 total
tiers in the battle pass yes
um there is a ton of value in that um
premium track so you get uh two full
armor sets for every class and they're
really themed to the season they're
meant to be like a celebration of that
season's theme
and uh and there's other stuff in there
there's the seasonal Mount there's the
seasonal Mount armor which you can see
here on this screen and then there's
just like a bunch of fun other little
Cosmetics like role-playing clothing
um you know for example we have like a a
big you know pair of white Bloomers in
there
um so there's lots of fun stuff to find
in the battle pass no that's what I wear
when I role play
I think that's actually a really fun
idea though so like it's not like not
necessarily like big armor or things but
just more
more other stuff so if you want to play
a particular role like there's options
with some of that stuff that you'll find
and you can mix that and match all of it
so you know you can create all kinds of
ways to express yourself what's nice is
that you just said there's 90 90 tiers
and the season is three months right so
you have quite a lot of time you have
the essentially 120 days to do 90 tiers
it seems doable yeah we want it to be
achievable yeah absolutely okay great
I want to call it one thing also then
we're looking at that image before
there's that top secret label on the
left yeah like that is ex like we that
is explicitly a link that will bring you
to some part of the Season Journey as
well the only reason it says top secret
is there is because it's got uh language
in there that I do not want to make sure
that anyone is able to read to give away
what's happening in season one exactly
otherwise people will know about the
zombies
you use the example Joe that's on you I
was just trying to pick something okay
I'll say something to the circus next
time whatever so actually that's
actually
circus in a field all right I'll talk to
people scary clowns yeah for sure um so
yeah okay cool yeah it's nice to uh it's
nice to get a little more information
the battle pass like out there right and
so okay so we had we talked about
progression yeah uh we talked about in
both in the season journey and in the
awesome battle pass and so now when we
think about what the seasons also
provide is like obviously you know we're
going to get we're hearing about balance
we're going to be hearing about hey how
do we improve people's experience based
on what we saw in the previous year
season and actually that before we get
into that can if I can interject I'll
steal one of your questions go go right
ahead oh yeah all right so one of the
things that comes up I get a lot on my
Twitter feed is around hey how do I
think about you know Diablo 3 Seasons uh
there's and Kagan said it earlier about
like your seasonal character that notion
of do I have to re-roll to be to get
into and experience the season and
experience the The Narrative rapper to
experience the mechanics to experience
the progression basically do I have to
start a new character uh yeah so Diablo
4's balance around the idea of trying to
make sure that that uh that level up
experience from 1 100 is really engaging
and fun uh and very Punchy when items
drop for you that your power progression
feels a certain way as you play uh so
you do as a result of that we do balance
around the idea of playing over the
course of a quarter character right you
can go you play a lot longer than that
if you want absolutely right you want to
make sure it feels really good to play
inside that nine day period we do we are
gonna be having players uh like reroll
make new characters with every new
season and be able to experience the job
the growth of of their character over
the course of each of those uh those
reporters and I think you might have
said about just because you talk really
fast I want to make sure it's really
clear how dare it no one has ever said
that about me I am a fast talker and you
beat me so the notion around though that
um you basically have to complete the
campaign at least once before you can
truly experience the season right yeah
that's true actually there's a couple
things that you well so once you unlock
a couple things you'll you'll have them
for your account from that point forward
I can just kind of maybe just yeah I
mean we get so many questions about it I
think it'd be good if we clear yeah sure
so okay so
uh so first thing is when you complete
the campaign on any character whether
you're playing in the hardcore uh mode
of the game or the normal mode of the
game no matter what difficulty of the
game that you're playing and you beat
the campaign on from that point forward
every character that you make you're
gonna have the option to skip the
campaign as part of the playing that
character so if you play the campaign as
part of the uh this this preseason
period before season one begins and you
finish it when you start playing in
season one you can choose to skip the
campaign as part of your playthrough
which means you get to experience the
new seasonal content right away
otherwise you can still choose to play
through the campaign in Seasons uh but
you'll need to finish the campaign
content before the seasonal content is
going to begin for you so just things to
think about as you play so that's the
first thing you get as a like have an
account level unlock for your character
as you play right the second is when
you're playing through the campaign
you're going to reach a point in the
story where you're gonna unlock your
first horsey and when you get your first
horsey uh Four Seasons once you unlock
your first horsey uh you're then going
to have the uh the ability to basically
Mount up with every one of your
characters in that point forward
including characters you might have
already rolled at that point having
unlocked it once you've got that as an
account level achievement effectively
for your of yourself and you'll be able
to start like future Seasons even like
start a new character level level one
after skipping the campaign or even
playing through the campaign in The
Following Season you're gonna be able to
like just go ahead and mount up right
away my horses in my cave with me yeah
your horsey baby yes the Horseshoe that
died is then going to immediately revise
zombies oh my God we have showed the
video people know okay okay honestly
about if I if I spoiled that moment then
I do deeply apologize and we should put
spoiler warnings like zombie horses now
is theme specific I think that goes
leans right into that seasonal theme uh
yeah yeah absolutely three weeks before
lunch yeah sure sound off in the
comments let's hear it
um okay so that's the the second thing
you'll have access to your mouth you
unlock and then the last thing is that
there's a Azure playing through the uh
as you probably played as part of like
the open betas that we've done and we'll
see again in SummerSlam uh you'll find
these altars of low throughout the world
server slam what did I say this summer
wow I really did didn't I uh so during
the silver slam uh you're gonna be
finding altars as well throughout the
world and when you collect these you get
two things one yeah you'll be getting
renowned which is going to be basically
used to uh get a number of different uh
you know uh rewards for your characters
on the on that realm uh within that from
that zone so new skill points do healing
potion charges things like that that
you've got a chance to see before right
uh and but you also get a permanent stat
boost right you know for all characters
on your account one of the main reasons
to go after the altars yeah right but we
don't want you to need to necessarily go
after them every single quarter uh don't
collect all of these we think it's
really fun particularly the first time
to go and find all these things right so
once you get that stat boost the first
time that step boost can apply to all
other characters in your account from
that point forward right yeah so you
don't have to get those together over
and over again and when it comes to
Renown you don't need to go get every
altable to finish off the renowned track
in each one of these zones shows like
the season Journey there's you don't
have to do everything in the Renown
track to get all the renowned you can do
it maybe I want to do maybe strongholds
are my favorite feature else I can lean
into strongholds or whatever so but what
you're saying is hey I played the
campaign I found all these altars of
Lilith the first time and now when we go
into a season they be are hidden again
but I still keep all the Buffs I got the
first time all the things that are
permanent like the plus two intelligence
plus two yeah God knows I need plus two
intelligence but and plus two strength
and what have you but the idea of going
and finding an altar to add more
renowned to the pool to progress I could
still do that like absolutely I can
still go find them if I want to yeah and
you get a little experience for doing it
as well so yeah they're still kind of
fun to stumbled across part of your
regular play experience within a season
you just don't have to get them all
again if you don't want to there's other
things you can do instead okay so I
think we covered the what's what sticks
around that's right so that's great like
the entries in your codex of Power are
going to reset so you have to go find
those uh those aspects again go to the
Dungeons and go to the dungeons again
yeah those are the things you ever said
yep great
um okay so that definitely a great long
term that was really on topic actually
in terms of long-term progression
because it actually is long-term program
Yeah by by the letter of the law it's a
long-term progression so yeah it drives
100 correct thank you but when you think
about what else do seasons provide an
opportunity for like you've talked about
like all these things okay we have a new
quest line we have new mechanics we have
all this progression but it's also an
opportunity to kind of react to player
feedback and also what you're seeing in
terms of the data coming in in terms of
balance or things that maybe we need to
smooth out and sand down yeah absolutely
so we know that you know operating so
operating a live service game with
Diablo 4 after the game launches and
Seasons come out you know that is going
to be basically it's it's the best
versions of this are always the
conversation with the player base as we
play in a conversation with Community as
we play so as we're going to be
receiving feedback and we're seeing how
certain features and and content is
performing that gives us opportunities
to sort of like respond to that feedback
and react to it with updates the game
now you know things take lead time so
once we if we see uh immediately after
launch that there's a there's something
that we could get maybe make an
improvement on it's tough to it like
immediately and very quickly turn around
like big changes but we want to make
sure that we are we are carefully
iterating to make the Apple 4 the best
version of itself that it can be as we
go yeah and this is like a it brings up
to the point like where we just had
betas and we we literally took the
feedback that we got from the community
which we you know were obviously super
appreciative because it just makes a
better game in the end of the day and
people will actually be able to
experience those changes from the beta
in in the server slam uh uh weekend this
this coming weekend uh because of that
feedback so players providing feedback
on our Forums on Reddit social media
we're always reading through all that
stuff to to have that so yeah and I
think it's worth mentioning too in terms
of the way that like in order to do to
have a game that has Seasons all the
time and sort of this like having
quarterly Seasons you you're not like
once we start like once season one
launches we start season two like season
two has to be pretty much like very much
in flight and that's what I think Joe
was talking about around the idea that
we wanted we're going to be as
responsive as we can so if there's a bug
or especially if it's something we can
fix on the server like we'll do things
quickly but if there's a big change it
may take a season to get there just
because season two is already mostly in
the can by the Time season one how game
development Works you're developing
things ahead of time unbelievable that's
why we know we have zombies
um and so then it's but just something
in terms of patience and understanding
is like the way that you have to build
seasons is you're basically having two
seasonal teams that are leapfrogging
each other with like you know we kind of
call it the odd team and the even team
to be able to be able to keep up that
pace and so that's why I was like oh I
saw this thing in season one it's
definitely addressed in season two it
may not if it's big enough it may be
that season one thing we saw is in
season three because it was big enough
to require that time so just absolutely
right just understand how that's all
working yeah it's like reacting to bug
fixes and other things that's going to
be another really big part of the live
service team's job right so like
everything we're doing within Seasons we
want to make sure that we're constantly
responding to that kind of feedback from
players and kind of making the game
better as time goes on but the other
part of the season is like you know
we've got a lot of positive response on
our character creation
um and it would be great to get keg back
in to talk about sort of how we think
about customization during the season
because we know they're like maybe talk
a little bit about what you can actually
find in the world but also you know what
we're excited about with the shop yeah
absolutely I mean the the game is full
of hundreds of incredible uh transmogs
you know that you'll unlock just by
salvaging gear and the transmogs in the
game really give you this um this power
the sense of like visceral power
progression for your character right um
and so they they're meant to really like
bring that to life grounded in Diablo's
story and its world and its lands
um and what the shop offers is a lot of
um diversity so like the way that we
wanted diversity of like the fantasies
that you can uh that you can experience
and that you can express so the way that
we wanted to support the development of
the seasons was to you know add things
to the game that players would
appreciate you know to create
art and beautiful things that are
grounded in Diablo 4's world and it's
it's uh it's art style but provide this
like array of class fantasies and
um so for example if you want to be like
a thunder goddess as a sorceress or you
want to be a big Barbarian that like
rips the tongues out of your enemies and
puts them on your armor very specific
slightly unsettling but very specific
you you okay that you know the shop is
going to help provide a lot of this like
diversity in the types of fantasies and
then you can take all those pieces and
mix and match them with the cool stuff
that you find in the game
um to express yourself all kinds of ways
one fun thing about this too like
players got a chance like I said ripping
is that the fun things
but no I was actually going to talk
about I was going to talk about our
previous bandages we've got a chance to
see a lot of players making really cool
looking customized characters in the
game and all the gear they're collecting
it's still very low level gear like
there's other there's a lot there's much
more stuff to go find wait there's no
wait till you get to the end game well
there's a lot more looks and appearances
to find as you're progressing through
more one of the things I love about the
the equipment that's in the game is that
we actually do Regional themed uh armors
so here we go oh this is not these are
side by side this is not my to my point
but it's fine it's good to speak to your
point maybe all I was going to say
quickly before so can you go back and
talk about this but I just think it's
really cool that we have like Regional
looks like the notion of like oh there's
a cause you know there's like a Hauser
look and there is a fractured Peaks
looking and that kind of thing that just
kind of interesting that when you go
into a particular Zone in the world and
you start collecting loot you're
actually picking up pieces that are of
that zone so you can actually dress more
like a person from that zone if you
wanted to that's right particularly of
the legendary gear when you're leveling
up 100 yes there's a lot more to
discover even after that as you get into
World tears and more did you want to
talk us through some of the examples
yeah let's take a look at some of the
Shoppers this is tongue ripping right
yeah
right there wow
but this guy I think his name is death
Raven um the shop guy um but yeah as you
can see you can see
um sort of like a side by side of
in-game armor for the Barb versus like a
shop armor I think I just wanna one
thing I think it's so funny that we we
accidentally got these really awesome
poses for the Indian cameras and all
this all the shop armors are just a
person's name
technically intentional
but yeah like let's look through some of
the other side by sides um
[Music]
and then we have uh one of my favorites
from the shop there oh yes and this is a
rogue side by side so you can see I
think uh the shop Rogue here is called
death Walker so keep an eye out for
um tons of really cool diversity I love
the tacits of the in-game armor and I
love the pauldrons on the uh the shop
armor yeah
the MTX is focused on collection right
like it's it's not like we're trying to
like put only the cool stuff in one
channel or the other there's stuff
there's awesome stuff to collect from
the game and the show and like you said
earlier like you can mix and match
create your own fantasy which is really
cool see now we're talking my language
with the necro but like for example so
if I really like the in-game look but I
want that uh the shop helmet like when I
buy that armor set I can take that
helmet and apply it to my in-game if I
wanted to yes that's right and you can
dye everything
too yeah you can dye everything in from
the shop and in the game
um I think there are eight colors in the
dye palette so yeah
yeah if you haven't had a chance to
check that out during uh during service
land you should make sure that you get a
chance to play the Wardrobe and try
dying some gear yeah yeah
so that's customization and then one
more thing is related to customization
not tied to uh appearances and looks
which I think we already have a good
coverage on uh but you'll also be adding
we'll be adding new like legendary
powers like I called up before and also
new unique items uh with every new every
new season make sure there's like new
builds and uh and ways to kind of like
create customized characters and those
will stay those aren't seasonal those
yeah those will be going the Eternal
realm as well as the seasonal realm and
they're going to be Evergreen they're
gonna be uh they're gonna be there after
the season is over we're continuing to
add to the pool and speaking of
Evergreen like that's true like there's
potential to add side quests and things
like that like there's ways to continue
to enrich the open world through Seasons
that will actually stay as people sort
of move from the season into the Eternal
realm or to the next season yes yep 100
we are looking for those opportunities
to kind of continue to add to the world
of Diablo 4 and continue to build out
Sanctuary these are things that we're
really excited about as a team and we
never actually I think maybe that might
have been the first time someone's
mentioned the Eternal realm but like
that is the intention much like Diablo 3
that a seasonal character will you know
be in the season uh playing everything
that we've been talking about so far and
the one that season ends that character
will then move to the Eternal realm
where it will live on and you can choose
to play there or you can choose for the
next season while the new season new
seasonal character and go again yeah
that's absolutely right so the
characters will get merged down the
Eternal realm at the end of the season
give you an opportunity to take some of
the stuff that they collected over that
period of time and then build new
characters part of the next season yeah
there's no reason to feel like
um like to shy away from starting a new
character on the season because you will
retain all that progress absolutely yeah
okay cool
um and so what about
um when we think about when I play the
main game outside of a season we know we
have Capstone dungeons to be able to
change my difficulty tier we know that
at the end there's some mysterious level
100 boss that I want to try to get to to
get you know max out and prove I can
beat this level 100 boss at level cap
like are there other things within
Seasons that are kind of like that or
how do I think about that sort of notion
about like this sort of looking to the
Horizon what I want to do well once
again Rod Ferguson I couldn't ask for a
better team up let's discuss the idea
relational challenges so with every
season we want to continue to build upon
the end game and the goals the players
can have for themselves every season of
Diablo 4. you know and we've got some
particularly Big Ideas as we go through
the first couple seasons in the game uh
when the game launches so with every
season but we do want to continue to add
these these really really Pinnacle
challenges for players to go and engage
with Pickles challenges Pinnacle
challenge
we all heard pickles zombies and pickles
yeah all right okay fair enough fair
enough all right I'm throwing some mayo
in there
this is the level of respect foreign
okay so basically uh we want to make
sure that we've got these new big
challenges for players to go and engage
with every time we release the season
and uh and as we go we'll continue to
add more depth to this one thing we want
to be very careful about is we're not
looking to just sort of like arbitrarily
continue to make the game longer and
longer and longer and longer to play
right that's not the goal again we are
balanced around hitting level 100 and
earning your Paragon points getting off
your legendary unique items that's
that's the the real focus of power
progression for the player want to
provide new and distinct opportunities
for players to kind of Express that
power new goals in the chase over the
course of the Season without necessarily
making like just more stuff that you
have to go through in order to play the
game so yeah yeah things are very
excited about new bosses new major
encounters New dungeons new new things
and then as we see how players reacting
to the game as it is we'll continue to
build in that direction as well
yeah and I think it's it's really
interesting when we talked about like
side quests and things I think it's also
true kind of for the end game is that we
may use Seasons to experiment with new
in-game features and then if it's
working really well we might decide to
keep it if it's not working quite so
well we may have it leave with the
season and then maybe bring it back
later and then like it what I like about
the kind of quarterly seasonal flow we
have going is that allows us to
experiment a little bit and see what
works and what doesn't and if it doesn't
work we know it's only there for three
months if it does work hey maybe we
should have it stick around so it's a
great opportunity to try stuff out
absolutely particularly leads to content
too so you should be able to bring in
like these really tough encounters and
different bosses and things of that
nature uh and then these mechanical
features as we see how they perform and
we see how players react to them we may
or may not decide to keep them on to
your point and if they're they're
particularly popular we just had to keep
them in awesome we want to hear from
players about what's working what
they're enjoying what's you know and
also you know what kinds of fantasies
they want us to make in the shop so let
us know anything that you want gameplay
or
um from the shop and battle yes like I
said earlier this is ultimately going to
be a conversation and as we see how
players are actually playing Diablo 4
that's gonna that's gonna help us advise
us on how we want to build Diablo for uh
corpse exploding necro look I'm looking
for a corpse exploding in that group I
think we got you covered you're gonna
have to stay tuned for a future okay
yeah and I will say like I know we
glossed over it really quickly but we
were talking about like meta changes and
things like that and like balancing and
whatnot that is included in the feedback
that is incredibly important for hearing
from players related to that yeah I
don't want to skip over that either
that's thank you Adam for calling that
out so you know if Diablo 4 is game
about choice we want to make sure that
we don't allow uh balance issues persist
so long that they start to kind of
interrupt or disrupt that choice that
we're trying to provide for players we
don't want like any one particular to
build to feel so powerful that there's
not a reason to put up to play other
builds within a season so we want to
make adjustments make sure that like you
know player uh bills that might not be
seeing as much play and you know get uh
buffed and adjusted appropriately make
sure that they do see more use as time
goes on that is important to us we will
make new changes on a regular basis yeah
we don't want one way to play we want
every class and to have builds that all
are equally as effective in terms of
being successful we don't want to be
like only Whirlwind barbarians can
succeed so only everybody's playing yeah
that's the ideal the reality is that
they're some every every season will be
like something's a little bit more
powerful than something else so we're
just want to make sure that the uh you
know the distinction the the the Divide
there is not so great that it feels like
you're making the wrong choice
mathematically to ever play anything
beyond whatever's concerned for that
moment right right it's not like RPG
players are Min maxers at all they never
they never try to do the most with the
least ever
um
I think like this I think for in the
spirit of managing expectations and
ripping Band-Aids off I do think there's
something we haven't talked about that
we should at least say Claire knowing
that we haven't talked about which is
leaderboards I think the notion that I
think people with Diablo 3 and even like
d2r as an example the main thing about
identity to our season is a leaderboard
um and so just saying that what in the
early Seasons at least for season one
and two there will not be a leaderboard
and that is something again as I said a
lot of stuff's already in Flight we
understand the importance of
leaderboards we understand people
wanting to be competitive in their PVE
play competitive in their build play be
able to show their Mastery of certain
things and that's so it's definitely on
our backlog that that is a thing we're
working towards to provide the player
community with leaderboards as we move
forward through Seasons but it's not
something you're going to see in season
one and potentially not in season two
again I'm just managing expectations so
you're not yelling at me on Twitter
after uh we hear you we know we want it
we're working on it it's just not going
to be there at launch
as soon as we can awesome